merci beaucoup Mickaël merci pour toutes
ces informations du côté de Tours et à
très vite évidemment allez on passe à
l'actualité la réforme des retraites
évidemment puisque le Sénat a commencé
hier l'examen de ce texte votez en
commission ça vient oui tout à fait
c'est pas vraiment une surprise puisque
la majorité sénatoriale de droite et du
sang du centre on le sait elle est
favorable à cette réforme elle a donc
l'intention de la voter mais à certaines
conditions le Sénat a donc apporté
plusieurs changements notables au texte
d'abord sur la retraite des femmes ayant
eu un ou plusieurs enfants elles
auraient droit à une surcote sur les
trimestres cotisés après 63 ans
attention elle ne pourront pas partir à
la retraite avant l'âge légal qui est de
64 ans dans la réforme mais si à 63 ans
elles ont une carrière complète chaque
trimestre supplémentaire travaillait
après cet âge donnera droit à une
majoration de
1,25% donc pour une année supplémentaire
travaillée entre 63 et 64 ans ça fait
quatre trimestres majorés et donc au
final une surcote de 5% on y arrive
autrefois du scénario là c'est très
clair autrefois du CFA hier en
commission la création d'un CDI senior
oui c'est une proposition de la majorité
sénatorielle là encore qui veut créer un
contrat exonéré de cotisation famille
pour les salariés en fin de carrière ça
coûterait moins cher à l'employeur donc
c'est une mesure d'incitation pour
recruter des seniors qui pourraient par
exemple faire du tutorat auprès de
jeunes salariés une pratique trop rare
en France racontait hier et Elisabeth
Doisneau Cora porteur du texte au Sénat
quand même incroyable que dans un pays
comme le nôtre en soit aussi peu
efficace sur ce plan là notamment par
rapport à l'expertise que porte les
anciens dans une entreprise et qu'ils
peuvent transmettre aux futurs
générations et notamment aux apprentis
qui sont aujourd'hui importants en
termes de nombre et qui ont besoin aussi
de cette transmission de ce passage de
témoins alors Samia création de ce CDI
senior sur code de 5% pour les femmes
est-ce que tout ça ça va pas peser sur
l'équilibre du système alors on n'a pas
eu de chiffrage global de toutes les
mesures qui ont été proposées par le
Sénat et c'est une question importante
vous avez raison parce qu'on le sait la
droite sénatoriale elle est attachée à
l'équilibre financier du système des
retraites c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'elle est favorable à cette réforme
avec un âge légal de départ à 64 ans et
elle en croire les mesures qu'elle
propose sur les femmes les seniors etc
ne menacerez pas cet équilibre René Paul
Savary était sur notre antenne ce matin
on l'écoute
faut effectivement garantir cet
équilibre mais les propositions du Sénat
qui sont véritablement des propositions
sociales qui prenaient en compte le
Seigneur qui prennent en compte les
maires de famille ne dégradent pas le le
rendement de ce texte enfin en tout cas
de l'équilibre de façon importante au
contraire ce sont par contre les les
propositions qui ont été faites avant
que le texte arrive au Sénat qui dégrade
l'équilibre budgétaire il ça va être
l'une des clés des discussions la
question de cet équilibre budgétaire et
est-ce qu'il est conservé avec les
conceptions du gouvernement ça va être
ça l'une des clés des discussions Sénat
on peut toujours faire des calculs qui
sont très variables de ça dépend par où
on prend le problème c'est sûr que si
c'est pour faire une réforme qui coûte
plus cher que le régime qui existait ça
sert à rien c'est ce qui s'est passé en
2007 avec
la réforme de Nicolas Sarkozy qui
touchait au régime
donc c'est sûr que ça il faudra regarder
de très près la droite elle se dit très
regardante sur l'équilibre budgétaire la
droite sans doute pas monsieur Pradier
en tous les cas puisque monsieur Pradier
était prêt à dépenser sans compter donc
on va voir moi je pense qu'il y a pas
que ça il y a l'histoire où vous en avez
pas parlé mais il y a aussi l'histoire
des réseaux spéciaux et votre invité
tout à l'heure disait que c'était
explosif il a raison cette explosif
c'est une injustice flagrante mais venir
supprimer les régimes spéciaux de façon
plus brutale que prévu sans la clause du
grand-père comme le gouvernement
probablement que ses propres à mettre le
feu aux poudres donc on va voir ce
qu'ils veulent il faut que il faut que
le enfin la droite sache ce qu'elle veut
est-ce que elle veut qu'il y ait une
réforme des retraites
servir l'intérêt général ou est-ce qu'il
veut faire de la politique et ne pas
servir l'intérêt général les deux sont
parfois considérables attention pas dit
le contraire mais si c'est pour montrer
son identité bon si c'est pour gérer le
gouvernement à mon avis elle va elle
fait fausse route ce qui ne sont pas
être le cas des sénateurs qui ont donc
voté en tout cas qui approuve évidemment
le cœur de la mesure qui ont voté hier
des modifications en commission mais sur
lesquelles le gouvernement peut les
rejoindre il peut y avoir un pour vous
le compromis va va être trouvé entre
gouvernement et droit de sénatorial en
tout cas j'ai le sentiment que la droite
a trouvé les voies et moyens de proposer
quelque chose qui soit de acceptable par
le gouvernement on avait entendu la
semaine dernière justement la volonté
des députés d'abord mais ensuite les
sénateurs les républicains vouloir
proposer des mesures beaucoup plus
fortes notamment en s'agissant des
femmes notamment de la non prise en
compte des congés maternités pour les
femmes et donc pour eux c'était
équivalent à proposer
la réduction justement de 64 à 63 ans le
report de Las Vegas de départ pour les
femmes ce qui aurait été jugé en
constitutionnel et donc pas acceptable
par le gouvernement et ce week-end dans
le JDD effectivement monsieur Retailleau
trouve un compromis avec cette histoire
de surcote moi j'entends aussi quand
même une partie des républicains qui
trouvent que cette surcote n'est pas
suffisamment à la hauteur pour réparer
les inégalités les injustices
le caractère aussi sexiste d'une réforme
comme celle des qui est proposée par ce
gouvernement mais je voulais revenir
ceci sur la question budgétaire et
financière parce que c'est quand même là
quand même la raison pour laquelle le
Gouvernement a souhaité mettre en place
ou en tout cas présenter cette réforme
des retraites c'était le fameux non
équipe et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on
peine à voir ils m'ont peine à avoir un
peu de transparence sur tout ce qui a
été accepté par le Gouvernement des
demandes des républicains combien ça va
coûter au final moi c'est pas ça qui
m'importe le plus mais au final ça pose
une question quand même de crédibilité
de ce gouvernement dans la dans la dans
l'espèce d'en-têtement qu'il a voulu
faire passer une réforme avec des alliés
de circonstances en l'occurrence les
républicains contre la vie d'une grande
majorité des Français alors seule
précision peut-être sur ce point la
seule seule chiffrage qui était donné
hier par les sénateurs de droite c'est
sur la surcote des femmes ils estiment
que ce serait entre 200 et 300 millions
d'euros par an je demande à voir à mon
avis c'est beaucoup plus que ça
sans doute c'est beaucoup mais c'est
pour ça que je on s'amuse presque
maintenant à savoir quels sont les
chiffres est-ce que vous vous souvenez
fameuse histoire on va encore entendre
parler pendant longtemps les 1200 euros
qui étaient promis à un million 8 de 1
million 800 800000 personnes chaque
année on est passé ensuite à je crois à
200-300 000 puis maintenant hier dans
une lettre que le monsieur le ministre
du sable t'a envoyé à Jérôme Guedj le
député socialiste finalement on est plus
qu'à 20 de 10 à 20 000 personnes qui
seraient susceptibles
nouveau chaque année mais Bruno Le Maire
dit quand même qu'il y a un million
800000 retraités
d'une augmentation de 57 euros en
moyenne oui d'accord on est quand même
loin de la fille de l'objectif affiché
dès le départ en disant et d'ailleurs ce
qui aurait pu être acceptable par une
grande partie je pense de la classe
politique c'est à dire considérée que
quel que soit votre carrière et
notamment pour les femmes qui ont des
carrières arrachées vous puissiez partir
à la retraite avec une retraite minimum
de 1200 euros ça pourrait s'entendre et
ça pourrait être un objectif politique
très louable et presque acceptable par
l'ensemble des groupes de de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat mais
c'est absolument pas ça qui est proposé
aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est symptomatique des
difficultés du gouvernement de
communiquer sur sur cette réforme et de
la rendre claire et lisible pour les
Français
vous savez ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que on est en plein en plein
paradoxe française c'est à dire que si
vous vous souvenez la réforme systémique
de 2017 c'est une réforme qu'on pensait
qu'il y avait vocation davantage de
justice davantage d'égalité puis quand
on est rentré dans le détail on s'est
aperçu que finalement c'était un tel
je dirais un tel un tel problème
d'unifié tout le monde que finalement on
creusait encore plus les inégalités
peut-être
bon alors aujourd'hui maintenant qu'on
se heurte à ce système paramétrique avec
toutes les inégalités qui surgissent on
se dit mais pourquoi on reviendrait pas
au système au système systémique enfin à
la réforme systémique par point donc
sincèrement s'il faut faire une réforme
il faut la faire je pense que l'objectif
c'est un qui est peut-être ce qui est
certainement plus de justice
qu'aujourd'hui parce que c'est vrai que
à force avec le temps beaucoup de
d'irrégularité je dirais ce sont
introduites dans nos systèmes de
retraite première chose et deuxième
chose faire des économies évidemment ou
en tous les cas que ça coûte pas plus
cher puisque l'avenir nous promet
justement d'être très coûteux donc il
faut essayer de concilier les deux mais
il faut arrêter de jouer comme on le
fait actuellement que ça me paraît tout
à fait déraisonnable c'est d'ailleurs
une des raisons pour lesquelles je pense
les républicains veulent aller plus vite
et plus fort sur la question des régimes
spéciaux c'est à dire que ils ont bien
compris qu'on allait on allait les
accuser d'avoir fait peser leur
proposition dans les dépenses publiques
et me poser fortement et que donc pour
eux ça va de soi que pour revenir à un
équilibre qui soit acceptable en
contrepartie on aille très vite sur la
question des régimes spéciaux alors
justement hier on en a pas parlé parce
que en commission il n'y a pas eu
d'accord rien n'a été adopté sur la fin
des régimes spéciaux juste pour rappel
donc le voilà le gouvernement veut bien
supprimer les régimes spéciaux de qui
permettent un départ anticipé pour les
salariés de certaines branches comme à
la SNCF mais une veulent supprimer les
supprimer que pour les nouveaux entrants
qui seront embauchés après la réforme la
droite sénatoriale vous les la supprimer
les supprimer bien avant mais leurs
alliés sont tristes ne sont pas d'accord
donc il n'y a pas eu d'accord en
commission en revanche ça va revenir en
séance il est tout à fait probable que
la droite sénatoriale
porte des amendements en ce sens
Laval des Samuel disait donc du coup ça
va être compliqué
je crois qu'ils peuvent bouger beaucoup
sans avoir l'accord de la de des
centriste donc on va voir on va voir on
va voir
cette question qui a aussi une crainte
de que ça fasse un peu de l'étincelle
du mouvement social et le 7 mars ça
tombe en pleine examen de la réforme
bien sûr on est quand même enfin je
pense que on a des parlementaires qui
sont conscients quand même de ce qui se
passe encore que je me pose des
questions parce que j'ai écouté avec
attention vos deux invités de ce matin
et c'est vrai que j'ai presque le
sentiment qu'il y a une sorte
d'indifférence de toute façon cette
espèce d'obstination à vouloir passer
une réforme qui m'est visiblement quand
même pas ni compris enfin si comprise
mais pas accepté par les Français ces
espèces d'obstinations à vouloir passer
en force à vouloir jouer celui qui ira
le plus à droite que moi tu meurs sur
une réforme qui est déjà franchement
franchement injuste et pas nécessaire
je trouve qu'il y a presque une forme
d'indifférence face à ce qui va se jouer
la semaine prochaine avec des syndicats
qui sont extrêmement déterminés encore
une fois j'ai dit si plusieurs fois mais
c'est vrai que Laurent Berger je ne l'ai
jamais vu autant déterminer vous écoutez
des syndicats qui sont quand même pas
des syndicats révolutionnaires comme
l'une ça ferroviaire qui décide de dès
un an de d'aborder la question comme de
de grève comme dans des grèves a duré
indéterminée c'est il se passe quelque
chose dans le mouvement social qui
risque de sans doute perturber un peu
les débats la semaine prochaine à
l'Assemblée
nécessaire puisque la droite sénatoriale
le gouvernement dit que cette réforme
est indispensable pour te sauver le
régime par répartition oui on n'a pas la
même droite au Sénat et à l'Assemblée
nationale semble-t-il c'est encore
quelque chose qui singularité française
qui est tout à fait intéressante non on
va voir une nuance de droite le
gouvernement
sans doute encore plus mais on va voir
on va voir si ce mouvement effectivement
sa capacité à résister sa capacité à
mobiliser sa capacité à bloquer le pays
on va voir puisque c'est l'intention de
mettre le pays à l'arrêt on va voir et
le ça ça veut dire que le 7 mars ça peut
avoir un impact pour vous sur les débats
au Sénat non je crois pas parce que je
pense que sénateurs sont très différents
des députés ils sont au-delà de tout ça
[Musique]
le débat parlementaire c'est quand même
le gouvernement en imposant sa
recours au débat limité dans le temps
pour parler du débat parlementaire la
majorité sénatorielle elle veut aller
jusqu'au bout du texte il veut qu'il y a
un vote finalement sur ce test il n'a
pas été le cas à l'Assemblée
puisque effectivement alors on peut
accuser le gouvernement d'avoir
entrepris de passer par une voie courte
mais il y a quand même eu la volonté de
la part des parlementaires de de déposer
des aidants par milliers qui ont bloqué
le débat et il y avait ils étaient pas
d'accord d'ailleurs si on prend la nuque
il y en a à l'intérieur de la nuque il y
en a beaucoup qui voulaient aller
jusqu'à l'article 7 et puis d'autres qui
ne voulaient pas aller il y a une vraie
il y a un vrai problème à la nuque j'ai
interviewé l'autre jour pour public
cédard et la Chaîne parlementaire
ricoquerel qui de reconnaissait lui-même
il regrettait qu'une chose c'est que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ne fasse pas partie
de leur groupe de députés parce que il y
avait pas de mots d'ordre c'était une
espèce de
d'un archi qui régnait à l'intérieur du
groupe il faut qu'il y a un vote pierre
pour vous Sénat sur l'ensemble du texte
puisque les sénateurs de gauche sont
plutôt sont favorables en vote sur
l'article 7 je pense qu'il y a vous
trouverez par un parlementaire qui vous
dira pas qu'il aimerait pouvoir passer
le temps nécessaire sur chacun des
articles pour pouvoir la monter pour
voir le discuter pour pouvoir se faire
mettre en minorité en parfois en
majorité ils sont là pour ça les
parlementaires et quand j'entendais vos
deux interlocuteurs précédents invités
de votre matinale il disait qu'il pas et
qui prendrait les les décisions
nécessaires pour si jamais il y avait
une partie d'obstruction de la gauche
qui sont pas franchement être le cas
j'ai entendu Patrick canner y compris
d'ailleurs les communistes ils ont pas
ils ont envie de jouer le jeu
parlementaire enfin je vois le jeu en
tout cas ils ont envie de d'avancer dans
les débats parlementaires mais que il
prendrait les voies et moyens
nécessaires pour pouvoir aller jusqu'au
bout du texte et je trouve que c'est là
où on manque de vigilance même
commentateur journaliste sur sur le
débat parlementaires parce que on a
envie que chacun des articles soient
débattus et qu'on est le temps de le
faire le problème encore une fois c'est
le parlementaire le cadre gouvernemental
qui est donné au parlementaire du temps
limité extrêmement limité d'une réforme
qui va être qui va profondément changer
la structure de la société et
profondément changé le quotidien des
Français c'est ça qui est aberrant et ça
devrait être ça qui devrait nous
préoccuper et qui on devrait tous se
dire mais c'est quand même une
aberration on va demander aux Français
de travail 2 ans de plus mais on va
prendre que 10 jours de temps de travail
de temps de parlementaire de débat c'est
ça qui va pas aujourd'hui dans les
mollets oui bien sûr le gouvernement il
le sait très bien si le gouvernement est
passé par cette voilà c'est parce qu'il
savait qu'il y avait une résistance des
parlementaires moi je dis pas du pays je
pense pas moi je crois sincèrement que
les Français sont résignés et qu'il y en
a beaucoup qui disent qui se disent et
personne ne travaillait plus longtemps
mais malheureusement ça c'est quasiment
obligatoire ou sinon et alors là c'est
ça qui est intéressant et je regrette
qu'il y ait que deux ou trois voix qui
se soit élevées pour défendre le système
par capitalisation qui existe déjà qui
existe ou combien dans la fonction
publique d'ailleurs avec la Préfon et
moi je trouve que ça c'était vraiment un
vrai sujet qu'il fallait mettre sur la
table parce que de toute manière notre
système para répartition si ça continue
comme ça et si on veut pas le réformer
il est il va partir à volo et le débat
aura sûrement lieu le snap c'est qu'il y
a un amendement de certains sénateurs
sur ce sujet on va passer à un autre
test qui sera examiné après la réforme
des retraites au Sénat c'est le projet
de loi immigration mais désir Samia les
deux ministres en charge de ce texte
Gérald Darmanin et Olivier du soft
étaient auditionné par les sénateurs
vous l'avez tout suivi oui tout à fait
c'est c'est un texte symbolisé qui
serait examiné après qui sera examiné le
28 mars prochain au Sénat ce projet de
loi immigration il prévoit à la fois
d'augmenter le nombre des expulsions et
de régulariser les personnes qui
occupent un métier en tension une forme
de en même temps en fait un carnet par
deux ministres auditionnés donc hier par
les sénateurs Gérald Darmanin d'abord
ministre de l'Intérieur de l'Intérieur
pardon c'est le côté pile de la réforme
celui du durcissement pour augmenter le
nombre de reconduites forcés à la
frontière il veut pouvoir faire sauter
les verrous qui empêchent d'expulser des
délinquants en situation irrégulière
serait concernée ce qui commettent des
crimes et des lits graves passibles de
10 ans de prison ou de 50 prisons en cas
de récidive il ne bénéficieront donc
plus d'aucune protection contre
l'expulsion quel que soit leur situation
c'est le retour de ce qu'on appelle la
double peine supprimer en France dans
les années 2000
si vous étiez marié avec un français ou
une français si vous avez des enfants en
France bref si vous étiez arrivé en
France avant l'âge de 13 ans et vous
commettiez les actes après l'âge de 18
ans il y avait un certain nombre de
protection qui était prévu par la loi le
miso ailleurs quand même vous auriez
commis d'écrire
ignobles ne pouvait pas vous expulser
nous proposons que nous fassions tomber
l'intégralité de ces protections
subsidiaires de ces protections d'ordre
public et que désormais nous ne
regardions pas la situation de la
personne selon sa vie privée familiale
mais qu'en gagnant le crime que la Comic
nous puissions expulser ainsi ces
personnes alors hier lors de cette
audition Gérald Darmanin a aussi dit
qu'il était prêt à limiter le
regroupement familial dans certains cas
et si ce n'est pas contraire à la
Constitution alors ça c'est pour le côté
pile du projet de l'homme il y a aussi
le côté face oui ça c'est Olivier du
soft qui l'incarne le ministre du
Travail il veut créer un titre de séjour
provisoire d'un an pour les salariés qui
occupent un métier en tension alors pour
y prétendre il y a certaines conditions
il faudra pouvoir prouver une présence
depuis trois ans sur le territoire
français et avoir travaillé au moins 8
mois dans un secteur en tension sur les
deux dernières années on va écouter tout
de suite les précisions du ministre du
Travail lors de l'audition hier au Sénat
il s'agit d'un titre qui permet de
régulariser la situation d'hommes et de
femmes qui sont présents sur notre
territoire depuis longtemps et qui
travaillent très souvent d'ailleurs
d'hommes et de femmes qui travaillent
parce que au moment où ils ont signé un
contrat de travail ils étaient en
situation régulière avec leur titre de
séjour n'a pas été renouvelés pour une
raison pour une autre c'est donc une
mesure qui est destinée à ceux qui aux
yeux du gouvernement auraient prouvé
leur volonté de s'intégrer par le
travail et c'est aussi une mesure
réclamée par les employeurs qui ont du
mal à recruter oui et c'est précisément
ce que Jacqueline stage brignaud a
reproché hier au gouvernement au cours
de cette audition cette sénatrice de
droite qui est assez connue pour des
positions assez dures sur les migrations
accusent le gouvernement d'avoir cédé
face aux employeurs qui chercheraient
une main d'oeuvre bon marché si on
n'arrive pas à recruter dans certains
métiers dit-elle c'est peut-être tout
simplement parce que les employeurs
refusent de se mettre en question sur le
niveau des salaires proposés on regarde
tout de suite un extrait de son
intervention assez tranchée hier face à
Gérald Darmanin et Olivier du soft on va
provoquer une espèce de main d'oeuvre
sous-payée ou peut payer quand même très
docile qui évidemment va pas gêner les
employeurs alors c'est une femme de
droite qui parle aujourd'hui et moi je
cautionnerai absolument pas un article
qui permettrait d'avoir une main
d'oeuvre sous-payée mais qui arrange
tout le monde ça c'est un vrai sujet
c'est un peu je vais aller très loin
mais l'esclavagisme du 21e siècle qu'on
cautionnerait voilà donc au final ce
texte ne satisfait pas grand monde ni la
droite qui dîne pas vraiment comprendre
au gouvernement veut aller avec cette
réforme du en même temps ni la gauche
qu'elle considère que c'est une
politique qui est trop punitive envers
les immigrés il va être difficile à
faire passer ce texte
déterminée en fait
un peu un marchandage
notamment de la part des sénateurs c'est
à dire de dire on va on va voter la
réforme des retraites et puis en
revanche on va se montrer plus ferme
avec la loi immigration et asile alors
c'est sûr que si vous voulez la loi
immigration asile elle a fait aussi
elle-même l'objet d'une évolution
intéressante c'est-à-dire qu'au début le
discours du gouvernement c'est un
discours qui se voulait très ferme pour
lutter contre l'immigration clandestine
et le raccompagnement sur leur vers leur
pays d'origine des des clandestins et
puis c'est devenu une loi beaucoup plus
mesurée avec une un projet beaucoup plus
mesuré avec un volet social donc qui
était destiné peut-être à plaire à la
partie gauche de la majorité bon on en
est là aujourd'hui c'est sûr qu'ils vont
se heurter alors madame
stash elle a une position qui est assez
singulière parce que elle son propos est
très fort et je pense qu'elle a raison
elle a évidemment raison de toute
manière c'est comme ça que ça va se
terminer mais si la loi est adoptée mais
c'est pas comme ça que à mon avis la
majorité de la droite va le prendre
parce qu'à force de vouloir contenter la
droite et la gauche le gouvernement
le sentiment qu'on contente personne
pour avoir un peu une sensibilité de
gauche je ne peux pas je ne vois
absolument pas un caractère de gauche
dans la proposition qui est faite par le
gouvernement et la sénatrice madame
Eustache
qui semble découvert qu'il existe un
esclavage esclavage moderne ferait bien
de regarder ce qui se passe chez les
travailleurs sans papier aujourd'hui
parce qu'il y a des milliers aujourd'hui
de travailleurs sans papier qui ne
bénéficient d'aucune protection sociale
qui sont évidemment à la merci des
patrons jetables à tout moment et
exploitable et non payable aussi parce
que beaucoup d'entre eux travaillent
mais finissent parfois par ne pas
toucher aucun salaire Olivier du sable
justement à Jacqueline de sajorino
disant aujourd'hui l'esclavage moderne
c'est les travailleurs sans papier et
leur régularisation permettrait de les
protéger davantage si on parle de
régularisation c'est pas du tout ce que
propose monsieur du soft monsieur du
stop propose un contrat
je sais pas on compte on en a une
trentaine maintenant de deux de loi de
gouvernement successifs sur la question
de l'asile et l'immigration je crois
on est proche des 30 mais qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé le week-end dernier 62 morts
au large des côtes italienne est-ce que
vraiment notre préoccupations c'est de
savoir quelle est l'utilité politique
quelle est l'utilité économique pour
notre pays de savoir ce qu'on fait des
personnes qui arrivent sur notre
territoire ou à savoir est-ce qu'on
expulse des personnes qui seraient des
possibles des délinquants non la
question c'est quel est le devoir
d'humanité on a vis-à-vis des gens qui
arrivent de l'extérieur parce qu'il fuit
les guerres parce qu'il fuit la misère
parce qu'il fuit le réchauffement
climatique dont nous pays européens
sommes responsables donc notre
responsabilité dans les déplacements de
population et des personnes qui arrivent
sur notre territoire il est d'abord un
de les accueillir de trouver les
conditions
d'hébergement d'abord les conditions
d'accueil digne c'est notre devoir de
payer européen et notamment en France et
pas de trouver encore une fois un texte
qui un texte purement utilitariste qui
se sert des personnes en fonction de nos
besoins économiques que je trouve
franchement totalement inhumain et
surtout des considérations de justice
qui consisteraient à remettre en place
la double peine qui n'ont absolument
aucun effet et qui n'ont surtout qui
sont profondément inhumaines
là dessus non moi je pense qu'il faut
surtout travailler et à l'immigration
clandestine à lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine ça passe par
des mesures et par une politique qui est
une politique qui considère les pays de
départ qui est une politique qui
probablement peut se mener aussi au
niveau européen quoi que le Danemark a
prouvé le contraire
alors que le Danemark appartient à
l'Union européenne donc c'est il est là
le sujet c'est pas tellement moi je
crois absolument pas au quota fausse
bonne idée je crois absolument pas à
cette histoire de régularisation des des
personnes sans papiers je pense que le
sujet il est pas là le sujet c'est
l'immigration clandestine c'est ce que
Jean-Christophe Rufin dans un excellent
livre à appeler l'Empire et les nouveaux
barbares et qu'il avait écrit il y a 30
ans il y a bien longtemps qu'on aurait
dû prendre ce sujet par les corps on
aura l'occasion d'en parler puisque
Samia vous l'avez dit 28 mars l'arrivée
de ce texte au scén Ariste
[Musique]